- Welcome everyone, and thank you so much
for joining us for the
Yale Development Dialogues,
a series convening economists, historians,
and policymakers to discuss
some of the most pressing issues
confronting developing countries.
I'm Catherine Cheney.
I'm a Senior Reporter at Devex,
and I'll be your moderator today,
as we ask the big question:
Is it time to re-imagine
sustainable development?
So, as many of you know,
the 76th session of the United
Nations General Assembly
opens today.
And, leaders from around the world
will be meeting virtually and in person
to discuss progress on the
sustainable development goals.
So as a reporter, focused
on technology and innovation
in global health and
international development,
I often refer to the SDGs,
really as a way to capture
the issues that I cover.
At Devex, our motto and
mission is do good, do it well.
And we cover what is really a
global development industry.
I see journalism as a way
to highlight what is
working and what isn't,
when it comes to making
progress on the SDGs,
spreading the best ideas and
holding the sector accountable,
which I think will be
critical in making progress
on these ambitious goals.
But, today we actually ask:
Do these goals make sense?
Are they the best way to set ambitions,
to measure progress, to
hold the world to account?
For those who are less familiar,
and I'll just give a
little bit of background
before our panelists expand on this,
the SDGs are a list of 17
interlinked global goals.
They were adopted
by the United Nations
member states in 2015,
and they focus on everything
from tackling poverty and inequality,
to improving health and education,
issues like water, sanitation,
clean energy, climate action,
industry and infrastructure, decent work,
peace, justice, and strong institutions.
And finally, goal 17:
Partnerships to achieve all these goals.
There are specific targets for each goal,
and indicators to measure progress,
with this deadline of 2030.
The SDGs serve, really as a blueprint,
for how to solve the
world's greatest challenges,
but they're also the
subject of intense debate.
And I actually think
the COVID-19 pandemic,
among other things, has
led more people to ask:
How realistic are the SDGs?
Do they measure the right things?
And, how can they really
hold up in the face of crises
like COVID-19 and climate change?
So today, we're joined by
several experts on the issue.
I'm excited to hear from them
on exactly how we should
re-imagine sustainable development.
I'll go ahead and introduce them.
Stefan Dercon is Professor
of Economic Policy
at the Blavatnik School of Government,
in the Economics Department
at the University of Oxford.
He's also Policy Advisor to Dominic Raab,
the UK Secretary of State
for Foreign Commonwealth
and Development Affairs,
and First Secretary of State.
Between 2011 and 2017, he
was the Chief Economist
of the Department of
International Development,
where Rory Stewart was as well.
You'll hear about him in a moment.
We're also joined by Shanta Devarajan.
He's Professor of the
Practice of Development,
at Georgetown University's
Edmund A. Walsh School of Foreign Service.
And his previous positions
include Senior Director
for Development Economics,
and former Acting Chief Economist
at the World Bank Group.
He was a Director of the
"World Development Report 2004,
Making Services Work for Poor People"
And, I'm sure he'll draw
on some of those insights.
And finally, Rory Stewart,
one of the three Co-Organizers
of the Yale Development Dialogues,
is a Senior Fellow
at Yale Jackson Institute
for Global Affairs,
where he focuses on
contemporary politics and crisis
in international development,
and intervention in fragile
and conflict-affected states.
Lately, he's been very
busy with Afghanistan,
as you might imagine.
He was previously the
UK Secretary of State
for International Development.
And in that role, he
doubled the UK's investment
in climate and the environment.
And, the three of these panelists
have worked very closely
together over the years.
And, as one of the organizers
of the Yale Development Dialogues,
Rory has really taken the
lead on framing the session
and saying, "This is why we
need to have this conversation.
And this is why, now."
So before I go to Rory,
I just want to note,
we really love to hear from our audience.
We always have great
questions from you all.
So, while I definitely have
some questions prepared,
please throw your questions
into the Q and A function on Zoom,
and I'll get to as many as I can.
But Rory, I do want to
start with you here.
This big question:
Is it time to re-imagine
sustainable development?
This really came from you, and you know,
I think you picked the perfect
people in Stefan and Shanta
to discuss this big question.
So, can you expand on why
this question? Why now?
Why is it so critical we
have this discussion today?
- I think the first thing,
thank you all very much for having me.
And, I obviously want to spend more time
giving you all the time
speak, rather than myself.
But, I think one thing
as an ex-politician,
which is important to frame,
is the ways in which things
like the SDGs emerge.
It isn't simply
that very distinguished
development economists,
like Shanta or Stefan,
sit down and try to think
in the most clear sighted, logical way
about the most efficient
research they've done
on how to do development well.
What, in fact, happens
with the SDGs, of course,
is that it is primarily a
response to another set of goals
called the Millennium Development Goals,
that came about in 2000.
And which, by 2015, we're
looking a little bit tired.
So in 2015,
there was another pump to
get everything going again,
this time with a target of 2030.
And, underlying an enormous
amount of what's going on
is a funny combination of
academic literature and research.
Right?
Which is transforming these goals
and taking them from the aid goals
with the Millennium Development Goals,
up to 17, and new things emerging.
If you dig under the surface of it,
a lot of what's happening in the SDGs
is this, sort of, critique of the MDGs.
So, one big change is suddenly
these goals become universal.
They relate not just to
developing countries,
they're to relate all the
countries of the world.
So, the United States, United Kingdom
is supposed to be signing up
to pursue these same common goals.
Much more emphasis on
things like peace building,
governance, human rights.
Much more emphasis on the private sector.
Much more evidence on
biodiversity on land and sea.
Why did these changes happen in 2015?
Well, because people obviously
felt two things there.
One of them is, here are
things which are excluded,
that we care about, like biodiversity.
Second thing, of course,
there is a political pushback
from people saying,
this shouldn't simply be
countries in the north
telling countries in south how to behave.
We should all be trying
to pursue these goals.
So, become more universal,
become more comprehensive,
also become far more ambitious.
Suddenly there is a commitment
not to halving things
like poverty and hunger.
There's commitments to getting
to zero on these things.
And, new forms of measurement come in
to try to guess how effective they are.
And I, as a working politician,
found this absolutely
central to what I was doing.
So, I would turn up at
the UN General Assembly.
I did a big session as
the Secretary of State
on the Sustainable Development
Goals, gave a speech on it,
run a whole series of different events,
UN General Assembly around them.
And we all talk, sovereignly,
about those things within
them, which we liked
that for me, as a politician,
obviously I was particularly excited
at the emphasis on
climate and biodiversity.
So, I put a huge emphasis
on that when I spoke.
Other people are very
interested in the shift,
just from talking about education,
talking about the quality
of education, right?
Other people are extremely excited that,
really, it allows them
to get into a (indistinct)
governance, human rights,
in a much more direct way.
But somewhere in the background,
you know, Professor Devarajan
and Professor Dercon
sitting there, looking
at this, and saying,
out of all this mess, of all these things,
generated by politicians, by
citizens, by lobby groups,
by NGOs, all of them are
feeding into this process,
what is getting lost?
What's been excluded from this, right?
Have we lost sight?
For example: As Stefan might
say, on a focus on poverty,
or have we lost sight on
effects on economic growth,
or if we lost sight on a focus
of actually what works
and what doesn't work?
Because I think, and it's on this
that I'm gonna hand over
to the other panelists,
I think somewhere within this, of course,
the great fundamental point,
which is that (indistinct).
You don't have a moral obligation
to do what you can't do.
And therefore, the fundamental question,
of what works and what doesn't
work, somehow concealed
in a series of incredibly
idealistic statements
about how we would like the world to be.
And, on that I hand over.
- Thank you, Rory.
Stefan, I do want to bring you into this.
And first of all, I know you,
as we critique the goals,
because I do want to start with a critique
because before we propose solutions,
we need to understand the problem here.
I know one, the goals are
idealistic, as Rory said.
And would love for you to expand on that.
And two, in terms of who
they are relevant for.
You know, Rory mentioned as
a politician from the UK,
going to the UN General Assembly,
this was a useful blueprint.
It served a purpose,
and he was able to use
these goals as a framework,
but perhaps, not so relevant
or useful for everyone.
So can you jump in on your experience,
in terms of, how the goals have emerged
and whether they make sense?
- Well, thank you very much.
And, look.
What is there to dislike
about as the SDGs?
You know, we should only celebrate them.
You know, we have zero poverty
in there and zero hunger.
Poverty is still there (indistinct) G1.
We have learning for all.
We have economic opportunities for all.
But also, lots more attention to planet,
to biodiversity, to
climate issues, and so on.
You know, we have there,
something quite remarkable.
Kind of a vision for Sweden
in the whole world, you know?
A beautiful blueprint for the world.
And we got all the leaders in
the world to sign up for this.
What more? Actually the job is done.
You know, maybe we're there.
And this is a bit like, well,
I find it actually really
quite problematic, okay?
There's a number of things
that fundamentally get lost
by celebrating and only celebrating,
and the way we talk about
and the way to do it.
So, it's not that I'm against the SDGs.
I think, indeed, it's
about their relevance,
and what we've actually lost.
So for me, maybe three points to make.
So the first one is, you know,
Rory mentioned the
Millennium Development Goals.
The Millennium Development Goals,
they came out of the Millennium Summit.
And there's this famous photograph,
probably the only time
in the global history
that so many leaders in the world
were on the same photograph.
I counted them. 149 Heads of States.
It was signed by 189 leaders.
They signed up to these MDGs,
and indeed, Rory said
they weren't perfect,
but they were the beginning,
and then the SDGs were there.
Now, I have a problem with that photograph
because I look at that,
and yes, I see there are,
you know, decent people.
I see Kofi Annan there, I see Tony Blair,
I see Bill Clinton, Jacques Chirac,
and maybe I don't agree with all of them.
It's there.
You see Jiang Zemin from China,
and see Putin there as well.
But actually, you have
to start looking further.
And then, you see people
that have been put in front
of the International Court of Justice.
You have incredible groups
that came to power with massive violence,
and continue to perpetrate
massive violence.
You have terribly corrupt
leaders there as well, and so on.
And then, you ask yourself:
Well, what's the point of signing up
to the SDGs or the MDGs?
What's the point?
Of course, to those
who are decent leaders,
and they want growth and
development in their country.
Of course, no country's perfect.
There is no Sweden in the world, really,
in that kind of idealized way.
But for them, it's just fine.
It's business as usual.
This is what we try to do.
And especially with the
SDGs, we can pick and choose.
And so, there's enough for us.
We can do something. It's good.
But, it doesn't make any difference.
Not for the countries where
it really would matter,
where poverty is terrible,
where economic opportunities are dreadful,
where there's no learning for all,
where there is a terrible
attention to biodiversity.
Who cares?
Nobody needs to, is
held to account for it.
You know,
calling them out on the
SDGs doesn't mean anything.
So it's basically, you know,
for the countries for
where it would matter most,
it doesn't do anything.
Now, we can say maybe (indistinct).
And maybe, the second point
is we should just be conscious
that it's probably, in the end,
this is really in the
end for rich countries.
This is basically rich countries
to have have an accountability framework
for what they do in the world.
So indeed, I know that
definitely for the MDGs and SDGs.
You know, where Rory was my
boss in the Secretary of State.
It mattered for DIFD at
the time. It mattered.
You would look at it and go,
"Are we doing what we doing?" And, so on.
So, maybe that's not so bad.
And actually, we can attest to that.
It focused more on
outcomes, than on problems.
But again, for whom is it relevant?
Does it really matter for
those who, fundamentally,
we should be even care about?
It leads me to the final thing,
and that's actually where it
really gets problematic for me.
We see, then, the UN sitting
out, we have the SDGs.
Now it's going to cost
you five to seven trillion
to achieve them.
And every time again, that's what we hear.
And, it's going to cost us that much,
as if there's a supermarket for SDGs,
where we can go and buy them,
and then achieve our results in the world.
Now there isn't that supermarket.
In fact, you know, people
may think it's calculations.
In fact, Shanta, you may want
to defend yourself later,
did one of the first calculations
of how much it was for the MPGs.
So, you know, you have disowned it.
You know, you have made
your original sin there
and you've clearly put it aside now,
and you've confessed your sins.
But, it's fine.
But you know, you get this impression
that that's what you can do.
And actually, if we go
back to the countries
where it should matter most,
it's not money that's the problem.
It's actually fundamentally, you know,
groups that are in power,
economic and political deals
that are entirely focused on
rent-sharing for themselves.
You know, as Shanta himself
is quoted in a blog to say,
you know, what would it cost
to get development in the DRC?
Probably infinity.
Because there's no amount
of money that you can spend
at a time on President
Kabila, who wasn't interested
in growth and development (indistinct).
He was only interested in computer games
and making a lot of money.
You know, you can spend whatever you want.
It doesn't make progress.
So what's the relevance,
if we focus on the wrong countries,
and actually keep them
focusing just on development,
as just something you can buy?
And it's just about spending
massive amounts of money
and that's all that counts.
I'll stop now.
- Thank you, Stefan.
And perfect transition to Shanta.
And I will say, Shanta,
I know you have been quite
upfront about, you know,
the challenge of putting
a price tag on this.
In fact, in preparation
for this conversation,
I read a blog post you wrote,
"Shame on me: Why it was
wrong to cost the MDGs."
And here we are, doing
the same for the SDGs,
despite the challenges
that Stefan outlined.
So, can you expand on this a little bit,
when it comes to the problems with SDGs,
why is this costing issue
part of the problem?
And perhaps, you have more to add to that.
- Sure. Well, thank you very much.
This is a real pleasure and an honor
to be in this (indistinct) group.
You know, the problem is,
actually, if we go back to the
Millennium Development Goals
that both Rory and Stefan mentioned.
Let's be honest, they were
essentially an attempt
to raise funds for foreign aid.
And basically, the taxpayers
in rich countries were asking,
"What are we paying for
all of this foreign aid?"
And they came out with
a set of goals saying,
we're trying to reduce child mortality
and increase primary
enrollment, and so on.
And in a narrow sense, it worked,
It did raise foreign aid, since,
and almost doubled foreign
aid during that period.
The problem is that we got
trapped into the situation,
which Stefan alluded to,
thinking that's all it took,
was to get the foreign aid.
And then we would be done,
which was the point I was trying
to make in that blog post.
But, I think it's
actually worse than that.
By focusing on the money,
it takes away from what
is the critical component,
which is the accountability
of these governments
to their own people.
The problem is with, if you
say, "Here's $50 billion",
which was our estimate for the MDGs,
and now it's five trillion.
Was it, for the SDGs?
If you say, well, that's
what it's going to take,
then there's no attempt
for the Heads of State
to actually tell their people,
"Oh, we have to make all
these tough decisions",
because the reason we are not
making progress on the SDGs
is that they're not
coming up with the money.
So, it gets governments off the hook,
rather than actually being
able to hold them accountable
for delivering on these goals.
So I think the focus on
the billions to trillions
is actually doing harm, not
even if that it's misguided,
not just that it's misguided.
But let me say on a positive note,
the other thing is that we
have learned quite a bit
about how to make public spending
effective over the years.
So the other problem, of course, was that,
if you just had the money,
it doesn't mean you're
going to get to these goals.
Oh yeah, and a lot of people
have been doing very important research
on how to deliver on public services.
And there,
I would say that I'd like to
see more effort by governments
to work with communities.
There's quite a lot of
rigorous evidence now
that actually having communities
monitor service providers,
can actually lead to better outcomes,
like reduced child mortality.
Transparency of information
is another critical component.
When people know what it is
that they're supposed to get
and what it is they're actually getting,
they mobilize and they
start demanding efforts.
And let's be very frank, different ways
of avoiding the political
capture of public finance.
That's the problem we have.
Stefan alluded to DR Congo,
but we have that problem
everywhere, including,
to some extent, in the United
States of political capture.
Now, there are societies that
have tried to get around it,
including things like
using electronic transfer
of social protection payments
that make it much harder,
it doesn't eliminate it,
but it makes it much harder
for people to steal it
before it gets to the
intended beneficiary.
So we have a big agenda here of,
let's put the stage
SDGs aside for a minute,
and say, how do we actually
help improve people's lives?
And I think, the agenda is critical today
because we also have this COVID crisis.
And in the middle of the COVID crisis,
there's been a big push to
increase public spending
on health, on education
and social protection.
All for very good reasons.
There's no question that
you need more resources,
but if we spend it the way we
been spending it in the past,
we're not going to solve the COVID crisis,
and that crisis can blow up.
So I don't wanna say, let's-
For the COVID crisis itself,
let's use what we've learned
about increasing effectiveness
of public spending.
But more generally for the SDGs,
let's drop the discussion of trillions
and let's talk about effectiveness.
- Thank you for that.
Rory, you want to jump in?
- Yeah.
So, just to try to draw some
of these themes together.
So I think,
that the first thing is
somewhat underlying the way
in which we think about
not just development,
but almost everything
we do in our society,
is we have an idea that
somehow we have a plan,
a some sort of template,
and if we just put enough
money and resources behind it,
we can sort it out.
And, we're particularly prone to this idea
when we're dealing with
somebody else's country.
If you actually were
charged with trying to work
with a ex coal community in East Kentucky,
you might be a little bit
more cautious about thinking
that you had some universal
template and plan,
and you were just going to come in,
and if you put enough money behind it,
the whole thing will be sorted out.
Now, why is it we have this thought?
Well, it's partly because
we find it very difficult,
politically, and this is me
speaking as a politician,
to talk publicly
about how difficult
development progress is.
But the reality is, of course,
that all of these programs
involve partial failures,
partial success, two steps
forward, one step back.
Many things don't work out.
But, we don't want to
say that to the public.
What we want to say to the public is,
we have a plan, this is
what we're going to do,
this is this beautiful utopian vision,
and if you just give us enough
money, we'll get behind it.
And, it's particularly
strange in the US context,
because in the US context, the marketing.
So Stefan talked about this idea
about development being like a supermarket
where you turn up, and for a
few trillion, buy something.
But, the other dimension,
that Stefan maybe hasn't
emphasized enough,
is the marketing of the product
in the supermarket, right?
What's above the shelf?
And in the case of the US,
right from the very beginning
of the development project,
under Truman in the 1940s,
the marketing has been about
scaring the American people.
Right?
He actually says, when
he's launching Point Four,
a Congressman says to him,
"We've got to scare the
hell out of people."
So, it's all framed in terms of communism.
And an enormous amount that then follows,
in terms of US development spend.
And of course, a lot
of the drivers of this,
in the 40s and 50s, it's
not European countries,
it's the United States.
It's arranged around this fear.
And, we had the same phenomenon
in Afghanistan recently
around counter-terrorism, right?
And, it is reinforced by
desire to have a simple mission
that you can explain to the public.
Now, what's the problem with that?
The problem with that is that
if you arrange all your programs
around this sort of simple,
rather targeted mission,
which markets well, which sells well,
which, as Shanta says, is a
good way of getting people
to reach into their pockets,
as soon as that narrative begins to fray,
there is a real risk
that you're going to abandon everything.
So obviously, we've just seen this
with President Biden and Afghanistan.
As soon as people are no longer confident
that there are terrorists in Afghanistan,
suddenly we're not going
to do any developments
in Afghanistan, right?
We hand the thing over to the Taliban,
we leave the country entirely,
we're going to impose sanctions,
and 14 million Afghans end up being much,
much worse off now for it.
What is the alternative to that?
Well, to loop back to where we began,
the alternative would have to be
to work out how to produce something,
which is neither the extreme optimism
of the SDGs and the MDGs,
these sort of incredible,
utopian statements
about plants, money,
nor a total grim, pessimistic,
"We can't do anything. The
whole world is impossible",
but actually begin to
articulate imaginatively
and practically what it would mean to work
in different countries
in different contexts.
Alright, what does it mean
to work in Rwanda, right,
which is a development success story
that has serious human rights problems?
What does it mean to work in Ethiopia,
which seemed to be a
development success story
with serious human rights problems,
and now looks very different
to what it looked like
three years ago, right?
What does it feel like to work in Ghana,
which some development economists
don't want you to work in,
because it's approaching
middle-income status
and it's no longer poor enough?
What does it feel like
to work in Pakistan,
where actually international
aid has really leveraged
because Pakistan's too big?
It's economy's too large
for Pakistani politicians
to want to pay much attention
to what any outsider is saying.
What does it feel like
to work in South Sudan,
where Salva Kiir effectively
is prepared to turn around
to the international community and say,
"Do you want to cut off the aid?
I don't mind because the
people who are going to suffer
are just the people in the refugee camps,
and the connected schools.
I'm not interested in
this project at all."
So it's producing something,
which is much more located
in a place and a time,
and is much more located in questions
of local power and politics.
In other words, to, to quote
my favorite World Bank Report,
produced four, five years ago,
the entire framework that
underlies that switch is,
that somewhere there is a best practice,
and all we need to do
is do capacity-building
and find political will,
is deeply, deeply misleading, right?
In the end, all of this
comes down to local context,
local power and local politics,
with a capital P, right?
Over the others.
- Thank you, Rory.
I mean, I think that is so well put.
And I'm typing as you go
because it just helps reframe
how I look at these issues, as a reporter.
You know, on the one hand,
Stefan has mentioned
that the SDGs are a bit
like a blueprint for building
Sweden all over the world.
And so, it's hard to critique
that idealistic vision.
And yet, that is problematic
for the reasons Rory just outlined,
that it really isn't just
that we have best practices
we can replicate globally.
Every place is different, context matters.
And so, how do we re-imagine that?
I mean, that's the big question
we're tasked with today.
I wonder, Shanta or Stefan,
have you been in rooms, or perhaps,
been leading these conversations
yourselves, in terms of,
if this is not the right
blueprint moving forward,
what might a better plan look like?
Or, is a global plan just unrealistic,
and this has to be placed by place?
I think the challenge there
is that doesn't really
bring the world together,
which is one of the
goals of the SDGs, but-
Thoughts for what re-imagining this
actually might look like,
or what conversations are
happening along those lines?
Shanta, do you want to jump in first?
- Sure.
I think what we should be
having is a conversation
about re-imagining aid 'cause
the real source of the problem
is we are still thinking of
aid as a financial transfer.
And that's, as Rory says,
when that financial transfer
is such a small fraction
of the economy, as in Pakistan,
they think that aid is not effective.
On the other hand, think
about it, if an idea-
If we generate an idea about scholarships
for getting girls into school,
that actually spreads
throughout the country,
that is an enormous contribution
to Pakistan's economic development.
And, it could be an idea
coming from outside,
could be coming from Yale
University, for instance.
And we should be thinking,
if that's where aid is really effective,
that's where aid is needed.
The trouble is there's
really not a lot of money
associated with that idea.
So, the politicians will have trouble
going and explaining that to the public,
that here, we developed this idea
that's going to get girls
into school in Pakistan,
and that's our aid contribution.
So we really have to switch around,
and you asked them about conversation,
this was this almost my
refrain at the World Bank,
especially when I was
Acting Chief Economist,
which is that I wanted the
President of the World Bank,
whenever he gets on TV,
whenever he gives his press statement,
not to start with the amount
of money they have let.
Let's start with-
Either start with how many girls
that we gotten into school,
or how many children have we
prevented from malnutrition,
or at the very least,
what are the three or four
ideas we have generated
that might get girls into school
or improve child nutrition.
And then say, "Oh, by the
way, some of this costs money,
and this is how much money
we're prepared to let."
But I still-
I have failed.
I mean, you know, you see,
even in the COVID response,
every speech David Malpass gives,
starts with the $60 billion or whatever
that the World Bank has pledged.
You know, meanwhile, there
are Africans dying of COVID,
who are in some sense, the
clients of the World Bank,
and this 60 billion doesn't
mean much to them at this point.
- It's such a great point.
And, you know, I often
think about the SDGs
through the lens of
the role of journalism.
And, I do feel that's part of the problem
in how this narrative is covered as well,
is journalists jump onto the numbers,
like this much was committed,
but the key questions are:
Where did the money go?
And, what actually resulted?
And, you know, weeks
after the press release,
when we moved on to other stories,
not following those commitments.
I think that's a critical part
of actually making progress.
I want to remind our audience
that we really want to hear
from you all with questions.
I see a few starting to come in,
but just go ahead and submit
that in the Q and A function.
And you can let me know if you
want your name to be shared,
or if you prefer to be
anonymous, that's fine too,
but we want to bring in your voices.
Stefan, I want to go to you in terms of,
you know, could this be a turning point?
And if so, where do you
hope things will lead?
- Yeah, I know. So, let's-
Picking up on where Rory was is that I do,
you know, I do totally agree with him
of this importance of
starting from place in time.
And just even Catherine, you know,
I just wish that journalists, maybe,
should stop publishing all
these big announcements
and pledges that everybody
made in money terms,
because I definitely, in last ten years,
have failed to stop my politicians.
And I'm sorry, Rory, including
you, to actually (indistinct)
to announce these big
numbers all the time.
And it seems to be a,
yes, it is a problem.
It's an endless set of announcements.
You know, yesterday we
had 1 billion pledged
in humanitarian aid for Afghanistan.
I don't know what it means.
And, I honestly don't know what it means.
And so anyway-
But starting from that, you
know, try to build this.
I think, the way I would
like to think about,
and in the end, because we are outside,
there's a lot of what
we do is outside this.
We need to, kind of, always
be conscious of that.
So starting from a particular
place and time, you know,
I would always start from
trying to understand,
and that's what I would tell
also our teams on the ground
to not understand the
nature of the commitment,
that in that country exists for things
like sustainable growth and development,
and poverty alleviation,
and just understand
where does the political elite want to go?
Where is it? Where does it want to go?
Now, that's and important question
because we usually don't start with that.
We usually think, oh, we're
going to buy some outcomes,
to do some outcomes.
Now, you know, spending money,
while it's really important,
but actually without that understanding,
we will forget properly to assess it
because I think there's
always should be two tests
of anything that's happening.
And it's whether it's public spending
in the country or outside,
to bring your resources in,
is that, of course, we should be keen
on making sure that the
money is used effectively.
You know, that outcomes
are being generated.
And, you know, that's a
good thing about the SDGs.
At least it talks about outcomes,
and it doesn't talk about
some kind of inputs.
But at the same time, ask yourself:
Why we do this?
Is this the best way
of using your resources
to create, at least, a chance
that the underlying
commitment to development
in the political space
will start improving?
And actually, you know,
when dealing with the case
that Rory says, you know,
if you do it in South Sudan,
you have to ask yourself:
Do I give an excuse to
Salva Kiir or Machar
to actually ignoring
entirely what we're doing?
I remember being, actually,
once as a DIFD person,
going to rebel-held territory,
applauding that we were spending so much
on health, education.
And this guy said,
"Yes, so I don't have to
care about these things."
Now, that's a real issue.
Now, there's other countries,
where Ethiopia a decade ago,
where you could say,
look, they wanted to try to do something.
Yes, maybe it didn't succeed
in the way we wanted it,
but you can work with them in doing it.
So, you have a sense of
that underlying commitment,
you use your resources, not
just to buy some outcomes.
Of course, spend your money
well, but keep on thinking:
Am I nudging this country
forward in the line,
in terms of an underlying
commitment to development?
And yeah, that's probably
how I would think about it.
- Thanks, Stefan.
I want to bring a question
in from our audience,
unless Rory or Shanta, you
wanted to respond to that.
Otherwise we're going
to go to some questions
from the audience.
But Rory, did you want to jump in?
- Well, let me come in
very quickly. I mean-
I think the other thing
to understand is this:
There's always the counterfactuals.
So this is the boring thing about life,
is that if one imagines, in practice,
what would really be involved
in saying we're not going?
I mean, Stefan's of course, right.
I mean, there's not much
point in reinforcing failure.
Obviously, there's not much
point in trying to help somebody
who doesn't really want you to help them.
You know, not much point
in trying to believe
that giving money to Salva Kiir
is going to really lead to much.
But the problem is that,
that is very, very
difficult for us to bear
because what would that really mean?
That would effectively
say, well, actually,
basically all the money we're spending
in South Sudan's a complete waste of time.
So, what? Are we not going to
spend money on South Sudan?
And let me give an example
that really struck me most directly.
Stefan's point, which
is a really good one,
about their elites isn't
just true of national elites.
It's also true in many of these countries,
but it will be differences
between different local elites.
So, in Afghanistan, for example,
from 2001 to 2021, 3 million people
in the Bamyan Province
in Central Afghanistan,
were extremely keen to work
with international community.
They had good local leaders,
all the investment we put
in went a very long way.
There was a fantastic explosion
of high quality schools.
As their women were going to university,
there was some fantastic
economic development projects.
But of course, we put almost
no money into that area.
Why did we put no money in that area?
Because that was the
peaceful area of Afghanistan.
Instead, the pressure
was to pump all the money
into the insurgency areas in the south.
The argument being, all these
people are trying to kill us.
And the reason they're trying to kill us
is because there's not
enough economic development,
they're all unemployed.
So, if we can just generate
some more economic activity
in Kandahar and Helmand,
then obviously people
won't join the Taliban.
They'll love the Afghan government more,
and our job will be done for us, right?
Now, imagine if I had won my
argument with Hillary Clinton.
I tried, you know, directly
with Secretary Clinton
to make the Stefan argument.
I said, why are we wasting our money
in Southern Afghanistan?
'Cause nothing you're
doing is sustainable.
You build a bridge, it gets blown up.
Your development workers
can't visit these projects.
Why don't we put the
money into the communities
in the center and the north
that want to work with us?
In fact, leaders in the
north are saying to me,
"What do I have to do?
Do I have to kill some American soldiers?
Do I have to let off a bomb?
And what do I have to do to get
some government assistance?"
But of course, you can also
understand as I tell the story,
exactly why it was impossible
for me to win that argument,
and why it's almost
unbearable people to say,
"Okay, we're going to turn our back
on Southern Eastern Afghanistan
'cause it's too complicated,
and we'll put our money
into the peaceful parts."
- Thank you, Rory.
I'm glad we're zooming in on
Afghanistan in particular,
in terms of how it highlights
some of the big problems
with sustainable development
with aid, as Shanta said.
I wanna touch on a question
we got from the audience.
And, I think it builds on a
point Rory was making earlier.
Rory, you were talking
about how, basically it's,
problems seem easier to
solve when they're far away.
And, I see that all the
time in my reporting.
So, for example:
Many donors in the US supporting
global education efforts,
and increasingly with SDGs,
we're trying to capture not
just butts in seats, right?
Attendance, but learning actual outcomes.
Shanta, I know this is something
that you've written on as well,
that all this money is
spent for education,
and yet, you know, kids at a certain age,
can't read basic sentences.
And, so the question,
just to sort of recap what
someone had sent in is:
Essentially, if this is
a problem that, you know,
people closer to these
contexts are better positioned
to solve problems, right?
And, I write about this a lot too.
Like, local innovators are
best positioned to address,
say, education challenges
in their country.
And yet, that's not where the money is.
That's what Shanta had
mentioned earlier, right?
So I guess the question for you all is:
How do we take steps when
it comes to re-imagining aid
from top-down, donor
countries giving money
with little oversight as to
where that money actually goes,
and how it results in
real outcomes to more,
as it's often described,
bottom-up, locally developed solutions,
working to target problems,
more proximity in
problem-solving and funding.
Of course, the challenge
is that's not where,
really, the money lies.
So, in many of the contexts
where we really need
to make progress on the SDGs,
if that's the useful framework,
that's not necessarily
where the money exists
to solve the problems.
So, ultimately it does come from far away.
So, thoughts on how we
change that paradigm?
Go ahead, Shanta.
- So let me suggest a, yet
another, outrageous idea.
But it's actually been
practiced in a few places.
You know, Rory mentioned, you know,
Salva Kiir is not interested
in dealing with donors,
but the people South Sudan
are desperately in need
of some assistance,
regardless of, you know,
what the leadership thinks.
And if we are essentially
interested in helping the people,
why not find a way to
get the aid to the people
without having to go
through the government?
So, the version of that is cash transfers.
Universal, basic transfers.
I would do the thought experiment,
take the current amount of
aid going to any country,
and convert it into cash transfers
that goes to every citizen of the country,
and ask, which of those two models
is going to generate more development.
And I think, I said, this sounds radical.
Although it's been proposed
by many people over the years,
but I think the USAID is now
introduced this as a benchmark.
You know, they say,
whenever you do a project, you
have to answer the question:
Would it be better to take
this money and give it out
as a pure cash transfer,
simply as a technical exercise.
But, I suspect that in real life,
we would get a lot more development.
We have a lot of unemployed bureaucrats
and World Bank officials.
But nevertheless, we can get
more development this way
and it may be worth trying.
- I'm really glad you
brought up cash transfers.
And I want to stay on
that topic for a moment
'cause when we talk about
ideas to re-imagine aid,
you are absolutely right
that cash transfers,
when initially suggested,
seems like a crazy idea
to a lot of people.
And yet, now it's really
becoming a benchmark
for donor agencies.
And I'll throw out there,
just in terms of how
quickly this has happened.
So, I started covering tech and innovation
in global development,
coming up on seven years ago,
and one of the groups I wrote
about was Give Directly,
which is really a pioneer
in cash transfers.
And Give Directly had
this revolutionary idea
to just give people cash and
see what they do with it.
And, I think part of why it
didn't initially take off,
or there was some discomfort
in the global development community,
is it leads people to ask:
Why not cash
for all the different
programs they're implementing?
If cash becomes the benchmark,
and what they are doing,
their livelihoods at
development agencies, at NGOs,
isn't performing better than
just giving people money,
you know, that may
leave them out of a job.
So, I think it was quite
disruptive, quite controversial.
And I would just throw out there,
as someone who covers tech
and innovation in this space,
I think part of the challenge
with re-imagining aid,
is there's a whole industry
built up around foreign aid,
global development, and jobs at stake.
And, you know, people
don't necessarily want
to address the status quo
if it's not in their
personal, best interests.
Perhaps, I'm being a
little controversial here,
but I know we want to generate
some real dialogue and debate
in this series.
And yet, you know, there's no
better time than now it seems,
given the crises that we've mentioned,
to really take a hard look
at how this industry works
and how to make it work better.
So, sticking on cash transfers,
whether we want to talk
about cash transfers
or other disruptive ideas and
why they haven't taken hold,
I think Rory and Stefan
wanna jump in on that.
- I mean, cash transfer's
a big, big subject.
I think it's true, of course.
Shanta says that there are
many development programs
that are so useless
that you would be better
at dropping cash out of a helicopter
than bothering to do
it in the first place.
And indeed, many projects,
where we spend hundreds of millions,
and achieve absolutely nothing.
That's for sure.
I think there is a distinction to be made
within cash transfers.
I think cash transfers in
the humanitarian context
makes an enormous amount of sense,
makes a huge amount of sense to say,
rather than the United
States shipping over wheat
from the United States, you
give somebody some money
and they go and buy what
they actually want or need,
which might be a tenth.
Why make something else
in the local market?
I think cash transfers also
make an enormous amount of sense
when it is a larger cash
transfer as a one-off payment.
If you were, for example, to give $250
to a poor woman in a
community in Bangladesh,
and it's allowed her
to buy some livestock,
or set up a small shop,
there's good credible evidence
that over a year or two,
she might be able
to significantly improve
the savings and investment.
However, I am much more
skeptical about the idea of,
essentially trying
to run other people's
social welfare systems.
And there are two reasons for that, right?
So the third-
One's humanitarian.
Second is trying to set
up the small business.
The third is basically saying, here are,
for example, in Pakistan, elderly
people or disabled people,
and we are simply gonna fund
the Pakistan government,
giving them $30 a month, right?
What is the problem with that?
The first problem is one of scale.
The economies of the developing world
are now roughly the same size
as the economies of the developed world.
And, even if we spent 0.7% of our GDP
in the developing world.
On the developed world
on developing world,
we'd only be contributing
to 0.7% towards their GDPs.
We couldn't begin to provide
the kind of cash required
to run social welfare systems.
But there's a more fundamental problem,
which is, I think, it would
be politically reckless.
It would actually destroy public support
for international development
programs over time.
Because you are effectively saying
to a grandmother in Arkansas,
I'm going to take $20 out
of your pocket this month,
and I'm going to put it directly
in the pocket of somebody else
at the other end of the world.
And this is not how people
envisage development.
People, if they think
about development at all,
were brought up to
think this is all about,
not giving somebody a fish,
it's about teaching them to fish.
They thought about development
in terms of technical assistance.
As Shanta said, bringing ideas,
bring infrastructure vendors,
doing productive investments
that generate much more
than the dollar's return
for dollar's investment.
And you cannot sustain, I think,
the idea that the public will get itself
into the world of simply
funding, with its own cash,
social welfare systems in
other people's countries,
when they're struggling,
they feel, to fund social welfare programs
in their own countries.
I think it's very dangerous
thing for people to do,
even if there was evidence
that these approaches were sustainable.
- Smart point.
Stefan, do you wanna jump in on that?
- Yeah, I'm just looking.
And, having lived through
what Rory is also describing
in terms of, you know, the-
Well, I recognize it. So, look.
You know, when we talking what
is most effective as aids,
I totally agree with Shanta.
I mean, we have a huge amount of evidence
that it's good for people, and it solves
in some of those fundamentally,
defectiveness problem.
I recognize what Rory describes.
I would actually say, Give
Directly didn't quite invent it.
I think DFID was doing this
for a long time beforehand,
but that's another matter.
But, I think the bigger
problem I would have with it
is that, while it's
solves a problem for aid,
it doesn't solve development and growth.
And now, it is possible
that we want to be skeptical
about outside is able to
influence development and growth,
and therefore go for
these aid's effectiveness.
And that's maybe the South Sudan example.
It's not a bad one.
I probably am still more ambitious,
what you want to be with aid.
You know, I don't want to be
as gloomy as (indistinct).
And also, kind of, that vision.
So you want to try it.
So, I'm very supportive.
I would also say, look, you know,
we haven't reached the end
to also trying out and doing
better with cash transfers
because Rory mentioned humanitarian.
It's still a massive battle
to get humanitarian agencies
to be willing to use cash.
And, it's amazing things you can do.
Just, you know, we were
recently involved in Bangladesh
in a fascinating thing
with cash transfers,
where we managed to get cash transfers
in the pockets of people,
five days before the floods,
peaked during a floods crisis,
because we could use forecast
mobiles on the floods,
and we basically managed to give them cash
before the crisis hit.
You know, you can do all kinds of things.
But, all these things
are very much outsiders.
I'm still a strong believer
in the end development has to be,
there has to be societal
ownership of development.
And this is, unfortunately, not saying,
well, we don't have an answer to this.
I will need to still find something to do.
Because we shouldn't
forget, and it comes back,
actually, to a point
that Shanta made earlier.
A lot of-
Well, most of the resources in development
are actually the government's resources.
In education, it's more
than 90% of the resources
in low and middle-income countries
that actually will be the
government's own resources.
Finding ways of getting them used well
for the benefit of people,
I think that's still a big
task of us of trying to see.
Can we help to lock this?
Cash transfers will give
us aid effectiveness,
but it will not give us
development and growth.
- Go ahead, Shanta. You want to jump in?
- Yeah.
So this is a perfect segue
because I wanted to pick up
on Rory's very valid point,
that if you go with aid as cash transfers,
that's still a drop in the bucket
in terms of the large
countries, and so on.
But really, this is comes back
to the question of an idea.
Why not use cash transfers
for the government's own programs?
I mean, I did an calculation-
Colleagues of mine and I did a calculation
about the oil-rich countries in Africa.
These are, you know,
Nigeria, Gabon, Angola.
They're all very wealthy in terms of oil
and very poor in terms of development.
And we did a calculation that said,
suppose you took 20% of their oil revenues
and handed it out as
cash transfers equally
to the entire population,
in this low population
countries, like Gabon, Angola.
Yeah, to some extent,
Angola, Equatorial Guinea,
you could eliminate poverty.
You could achieve goal
one tomorrow with that.
That shows you the extent
of mis-spending of public resources.
And then the question,
and I think Rory was alluding to this
about the political support for aid,
the real question is:
Of course, development is not
just about people having money
to spend on food, and
clothing, and things like that.
It's all about public goods.
And presumably, that's
why governments exist
to actually provide those public goods.
But the truth is that in many countries,
many low and middle income countries,
the governments are not
providing public goods.
They're stealing the money, right?
And the reason for it is that
in the resource-rich countries
and in the aid-dependent
countries, I might add,
the governments are not
accountable for their spending
because they're not coming from taxpayers
in those countries.
They're coming from
taxpayers and other countries
or oil consumers in other countries.
So, you could think of a
situation where, let's say,
a resource-rich country
hands over all the revenues
as cash transfers to the citizens,
and then taxes them to
finance public goods.
And we can show, I mean,
I've been doing some
research on this recently,
can show that that actually can lead
to greater accountability
by the governments,
than what you have now, which
is really no accountability.
- Go ahead, Rory.
I think this is all fascinating.
I mean, I just keep encouraging
people to try to do,
because Stefan and I went through this,
very painfully, with DIFD,
where we found ourselves dealing
with an incredible buildup
of particularly conservative
political opposition
to the 0.7% that we were spending,
that eventually led to the
merge in the department,
and cutting of our budget.
And one of the things that going on,
one of the reasons people are not aware
that DIFD was doing this
stuff before Give Directly
is because DIFD did it almost in secret.
It's very, very difficult to
find very much information
about what DIFD was doing on
cash transfers on the web.
I went very carefully through their
testimony parliamentary committees,
through their strategic plans,
through their statements.
Because at some level, subconsciously,
DIFD officials must've sensed
that what they were doing
was not something that was
going to be very popular
with the public, and that
they would find very difficult
to sell to the public, right?
Now, it's very easy
for technocrats to say,
"Well, that's fine. We've
got the right answer.
We've done the right research.
This is the right thing to do.
And foolish, populist public,
they don't understand what we're doing.
So we'll just keep doing it.
And we'll just not tell you about it."
But, it doesn't work. It blows
up your face, eventually.
You need to have projects
that the public can relate to.
And this too,
I think is the problem that
Shanta's wonderful idea,
that we give all the
money in cash transfers
to people in Gabon,
and the government of Gabon
then taxes those people
and puts the money into the Gabon budget,
and then spends it out.
I really doubt that you
are going to be able to say
to the British taxpayer,
"We are going to take 10
billion pounds a year off you,
and the way we're going to
spend it is going to hand it out
in cash to all these people in Gabon.
And then, the Gabon government
is going to tax our cash and put it back.
And this Gabon president,
who we might not approve of,
is then going to have discretion
about how to spend it."
Right?
So, the problem underlying the whole thing
is that, understandably,
there's a culture that assumes
that if research economists
come up with the right model,
we can somehow trick the
public in wealthy countries
into providing them money
in order to follow
through on these schemes.
But, we can't.
Because we are failing to
understand the type of emotional,
empathetic arguments that you
would actually need to make
to the public to actually
believe in what's happening.
And, that's also why
certain kinds of things,
which we stopped doing,
we may need to think about doing again.
So, it's extremely
unfashionable, for example,
and it has been probably since the 1950s,
for internationals to try some
run high quality institutions
in other people's countries.
It's possible to do.
Like, the Aga Khan Development Network
runs an extremely good nursing
school in East Africa, right?
You can find examples of doing this.
And my instinct is that you
could sell to Swedish voters,
Swiss voters, British
voters, American voters.
We are running a
fantastic university here.
We're running a fantastic hospital here.
But it's profoundly offensive
to development economists.
It's profoundly offensive
to the academic world.
And one of the problems
that I had, as a politician,
is trying to get people to be practical
about what kind of things
you should do on the ground
that would actually excite
the domestic public,
make them feel this is
something to look at,
something they could be proud of,
something tangible that they can see.
And, I think, we fool
ourselves into thinking
that we can sell things that
are fundamentally unsellable.
- Thank you, Rory. Well put.
And we just have a few minutes left.
I can't believe that this
conversation is flown by,
but I want to come back
to each of you because,
in terms of the "why now"
of this conversation.
One key reason,
in terms of why to have
this conversation now is,
as I mentioned at the outset,
the UN General Assembly.
So, it kicks off today.
There will be several weeks.
Next week is kind of the key week.
But, several weeks of big conversations
that sort of take the
SDGs as a given, right?
Like the SDGs as a starting point,
and then talking about how have we done,
how can we, you know, get to zero,
achieve these goals by 2030, et cetera.
I think it's really valuable
to create this space,
to challenge the whole notion of the SDGs
and talk about re-imagining
sustainable development
and re-imagining aid.
So thank you, Rory and our panelists,
for sharing your insights on this.
But before we close,
given that the UN General
Assembly is now underway,
I would love to just go
back to each of you in here.
If you could gather all these leaders
who are coming together
to discuss progress
on the goals, with 2030 coming up,
and lots of challenges posed to progress.
In fact, we've actually
regressed on a lot of these goals
over the course of the pandemic.
What would your key message be?
And, perhaps, we'll start
with Shanta and Stefan
and then close with Rory.
But Shanta, can I start with you?
- Okay.
My key message to the leaders
gathering at the UN General Assembly
is actually derived from our
conversation here, which is:
If you want to achieve
progress on the SDGs,
you have to be more
accountable to your own people.
That's where you are failing,
and I'll be very blunt about it.
Now, as I was saying earlier,
I think the aid establishment
may have contributed to
this lack of accountability,
or weakening of accountability.
So we have to do our part
as well, but you know,
this is one criticism I have of the SDGs,
is that we have 17 goals,
but there's one goal,
I think it's goal 16, which
is the one on governance.
That is primordial.
That's the goal
that's going to generate
all the other goals,
but since it's number 16
of 17, it's easy to say,
well, you know, we'll focus
on the other three or four
of the other 17, and not
take seriously that one goal.
And that's, that's my
message to all these leaders.
- Yeah, that is absolutely
cross-cutting and foundational.
Agreed.
Stefan, what about you?
What would your message be?
- My message would be,
potentially, it's a version of it.
Although I always struggle
with the word "accountability"
because it also gets interpreted
in so many different ways,
but my message to them would be,
is that I probably would
put them into groups.
There are some countries,
in their own way,
probably committed to
develop them to growth,
to actually doing some of
the longer term things.
And I wish I could, on
behalf of my department, say:
Look, we'll support you
in that quest, you know.
We allow you to gamble on development.
And then, I will take that
other group there and say:
Look, you know, don't expect us
to keep on just trying
to compensate for you
because, actually for the
reason that Rory says,
we can't really permanently
overcome the fact
that you're not want to do this,
but if you show commitment to
doing some of these things.
And maybe in Shanta's words,
if you show accountability,
we will be there and we
will want to support you.
But it means also, we
can't just in general, say:
We'll write you a check anyway,
we'll just be there as
outsiders, you know.
Aid is a bit like dancing the tango.
If you're not both committed,
it's going to go very, very wrong.
- I love that analogy.
And surprisingly, had not heard
it before, but that's great.
Rory, we'll close with you.
What would your message be?
- I think moderation, pragmatic messaging.
The biggest danger in
international development
is that we produce these utopian dreams,
and in doing so,
we are going to inevitably
disillusion ourselves,
alienate our public,
destroy the credibility
of our entire project,
and run the risk that we
lurch from utopian dreams
to sudden extreme cutbacks, abandonment.
Now, the UK government
has just brought through,
in effect, 70-80% cuts
in many of these fragile
conflict-affected states
in its programming,
because of the way it's
structured its budgets.
And it ended up doing that, in part,
because of this ridiculous cycle
between fairy story and isolation.
So, unless we can get ourselves
to framing a moderate,
pragmatic way of talking
about development,
that it embraces the fact
that there will be partial
successes, partial failures,
that things on the ground
are going to look very messy,
and that we're going to partner together
and listen together, in
the way that we would
with difficult communities
or challenged communities
in the United States or Europe,
communities that we would expect
to work with over 50-60 years,
and don't have all the answers to,
we're going to find ourselves
in a hysterical, unsustainable situation.
We need to keep faith and hope.
And hope, above all, needs
to be rooted in realism.
- Thank you, Rory.
It's a powerful way to close.
Probably should just end it at that.
But I did want to quickly say,
for those of you who are
joining us for the first time,
or unaware, this is part of a series.
And it's the eighth in the series
of the Yale Development Dialogues.
And, I'm super grateful to
moderate these conversations,
bringing together insights from history,
and economics and policy.
It's really rare to have these
kinds of candid conversations
on such critical issues,
affecting all countries, really.
And I can't think of a more timely,
important topic as this one.
So, thank you again to
Rory, and to Shanta,
and to Stefan for taking the time
to tackle this big question
about re-imagining sustainable
development and aid
as the UN General Assembly kicks off.
And stay tuned for our
upcoming conversations,
tackling some other big
topics on health, on climate,
and we'll conclude this fall semester,
for those of you following
the academic year,
we'll conclude the year with
a conversation on Afghanistan.
So, thank you all. And,
we'll see you next time.